September 22nd of last fall was the 30
year anniversary of me filing bankruptcy
because I was stupid 30 years ago I went
broke because I was stupid you ever done
something stupid if you didn't raise
your hand you're stupid because you've
all done something stupid and I've done
something stupid and we've all the trick
is to not do the same stupid thing twice
because it hurts when you do stupid it
leaves a mark I went broke because I
borrowed too much money and on top of
that I did it poorly I had a lot of
90-day notes I was doing flipped this
house before there was cable TV to tell
you how and our bank got sold to another
bank and they called her notes and we
over two and a half period two and a
half year period lost everything we
owned when we hit bottom we had a
brand-new baby a toddler marriage
hanging on by a thread it was 28 years
old and I started studying what the
scriptures say about money because I was
a new Christian and there's a lot of
scriptures that talk about money like
2500 of them in the Bible and I started
studying old rich people
I did not want young rich people's
opinion I had been him I was a
millionaire making $250,000 a year at 25
years old in nineteen eighty five
dollars I didn't want his opinion he
thought he was hot stuff and he wasn't
he was just a hot mess I didn't need his
opinion so I talked to old people that
had money and I looked at the Bible and
they said the same thing
slow and steady live on less than you
make live on a plan and avoid debt by
the way when we just finished the study
of 10,000 millionaires you know what
they did slow and steady
lived on less than they make invested
steady invested steady and avoided debt
your most powerful wealth building tool
is your income and when you don't have
any payments you can build wealth
but when you give it all to car payments
and student loans Sallie Mae payments
Sallie Mae's got her own bedroom at your
house and you continue to use Discover
card because you're so stupid you think
points are gonna make you rich
Citibank what's in your wallet money I
quit borrowing money the borrower is
slaved for the lender 100% of the
biblical references to debt are negative
it's not a Salvation issue and it's not
a sin it's just biblically and common
sensical II stupid because when you
don't have any payments it's fairly easy
to build wealth so how do you get out of
debt well I'm a math nerd I have all
these letters and licenses after my name
that says I'm supposed to know something
about money I dropped all the licenses
because they tried to tell me what I
could say on the radio no selling that
crap anyway so we're out of the license
business but I've got all the letters
after my name stuff says you're supposed
to know something about money so as an
official math nerd I knew the proper way
to pay off debt was highest interest
rate first because that's mathematically
correct and everyone knows this is a
math problem until I started doing
coaching with people 25 years ago and
starts showing people how to get out of
debt and showing people how not to lose
their home when they're in foreclosure
and how not to lose their car when
they're in a repossession and how to get
the credit card off their back when
they're four months behind and get
caught up and get paid off I started
figuring out this thing about debt
reduction was more about my behavior
than it was about math the problem with
your money is the guy in your mirror the
gal in your mirror the problem with my
money is the guy I shave with he's got
problems if I can get him to behave he
can live on less than he makes and get
out of debt and build wealth but it's a
behavior problem and guess what you
don't solve a behavior problem with a
math solution you solve a behavior
problem or the behavior solution and
that's when we came up with and started
using the debt snowball which has been
roundly and widely criticized by math
nerds everywere is not being
mathematically correct as if we didn't
freaking already know that you doofuses
seriously the death snowball the only
problem with the death snowball is it
works the paying off the highest
interest rate doesn't work because
people don't stick with it when you pay
off your smallest debt you get excited
and you stay with it when you pay off
your next smallest debt you get excited
and you stay with it when you pay off
your next debt you get more excited and
you cut deeper and you sacrifice more
and you work harder the more progress
you make the more excited you get the
harder you push people losing weight
they lose one pound they get excited
they lose ten pounds they start to get
really excited when they've lost thirty
pounds they are on fire you can't tell
them nothing they know everything and
you know why cuz they're having an
experience and a man with an experience
is not at the mercy of a man with an
opinion you can write a blog about Dave
Ramsey and all the things that are wrong
with him and posted its clickbait from
your mother's basement if you want but
at the end of the day I've gotten more
people out of debt than anybody else on
this planet because I've shown more how
people how to do it and I've taught them
how to do it and this freaking works
it's that simple
so Northwestern University in Chicago
decided they were going to study the
proper ways to get out of debt the
conclusion of their study was the debt
snowball works because it's behavior
based better than any other method
people actually have a higher
probability of completing the plan and
of continuing on the plan and of getting
more intense and actually getting out of
that faster than when they did it
mathematically correct then Time
magazine picks up that story and says
turns out Dave Ramsey was right after
I'd already gotten 5 million people out
of debt they figured that out thank you
for your research it's kind of funny
actually if you think about it who was
it taught me to go into debt that would
be my finance professor in college that
taught me the power of using OPM other
people's money the power of leverage Oh
Dave I'm gonna borrow money on my
zero-turn lawnmower at 0% interest so
that I don't have to pull my money out
of my bank account at 2% people do
stupid analysis like that when they
don't look at debt
properly and that's a stupid analysis it
really is he's gonna end up with a debt
on a zero-turn freaking lawnmower give
me a break seriously you might be a
redneck oh my gosh
I've done so many dumb things I can see
dumb a mile away y'all I got a PhD in to
UM B so I'm not picking on you I'm just
picking on you because I know what works
that's not arrogance it's experience
decades with millions of people
experience so you list your debts
smallest to largest
you pay minimum payments on everything
but the little one and you attack the
little one with a vengeance when the
smallest debt is gone you take the
payments you used to pay there and you
attack the next one down if you want
some help doing this I'm gonna set you
up with a three day free email series on
getting out of debt just go to Dave
Ramsey comm slash snowball and you can
get the brand-new free three-day email
series on getting out of debt Dave
Ramsey comm slash snowball this is your
time this is your year
you got a whiteboard it's time to get
started you hear all these other people
doing it when are you gonna do it Dave
Ramsey calm slash snowball hey free
three-day email series to help you get
going